welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and the walking
dead dropped an episode that I had to do
a breakdown on due to this year's
schedule being extra busy I'm not being
able to go over the show as much as I'd
like to but with everything getting
canceled because of our own outbreak
I've had some time Frida now I'm ready
to bat for the other team like negan did
nah I swear that's not me dude but you
know it's cause he has a baseball bat
knee he's joined the whisperers look
we're gonna be talking about the big bad
exit of everyone's favorite alpha female
and discussing what it could mean for
the future there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the episode yet then I highly
suggest that you turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
recap without the way thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of The Walking Dead okay
so it goes without saying that this has
been one of the best seasons of The
Walking Dead so far excusing the
weirdest onscreen kiss since Michael
planted one on Oscar in the office
things have been a boiling point all the
way through whilst the whisper war
wasn't over the top and flashy for the
most part every episode has had some
really memorable moments and it's been
awesome seeing the psychological toll
that the entire thing is taken on our
characters I've covered the first part
of the season so if you want to watch
all of the breakdowns on that then I'll
link it at the end but just a quick
recap of things so far after escaping
the cave things really came to a head
with Daryl getting closer to alpha that
he'd like to and the group preparing for
war beta broke into Alexandria and one
of the best impressions of Michael Myers
that I've ever seen and Eugene started
his own radio station it all came to a
head at the end of the eleventh episode
with alpha unleashing the horde negan
has been slowly winning her affections
and mister steal yo girl has completely
blindsided her this kind of plays into
the end that I'll be talking about in
just a bit but re watching this season
they definitely laced it
the subtext at several points anyway
we'll talk about that at the end of the
video as the battle has a lot - impact
from it like Jurassic Park those
electric fences only last so long and we
were tracked to an agonizing cliffhanger
that made me feel like I had to self
isolate for a week to get over it
it's not my proudest one that one the
barricades of hilltop was set alight and
the walls came crumbling down episode 12
kick-started everything with a massive
showdown that felt very games of Thrones
II and the hour-long entry didn't
disappoint the battle at Hilltop before
the title scene was brilliant but in the
grand scheme of things it just felt like
a starter in what would end up becoming
the best main course in the show's
history everything was on fire from the
protection of the settlements all the
way up to the mansion itself and this
hellish environment really complemented
the hellish aesthetic of the show it
reminded me of Helm's Deep get it cuz
Hell hellish never mind they do a
fantastic job of launching projectiles
and the direction here is brilliant -
with us getting a real sense of the size
of the Horde and how much effort it's
causing just a five minute a minute
luckily the piles of the undead create
their own barricades and this holds back
a lot of those trying to swarm in
unfortunately a massive explosion blows
a hole in the fence allowing more of the
walkers to pile in the survivors fall
back and leave the location all
splitting up and Eugene grabs his radio
equipment which I think will pay off
later
now skipping ahead a bit negan is of
course a double agent this shouldn't
come as a surprise if you've read the
comics but they handled it slightly
different in the show which did keep me
guessing his true intentions the next
morning we get negan on cleaning duty
and know in hindsight he was being cruel
to be kind
at the time I did get a lot of
flashbacks to Glenn beta tries his best
to escape the friend zone and frown emic
two knives since negan out to round up
the walkers for the herd I just love
watching Jeffrey Dean Morgan in the show
and hats off to whoever managed to get
him involved because he's slowly
becoming the best character when
scouting he spots a limping Lydia and
then stumbles across Aaron he tries to
explain it but he's interrupted by some
walkers and finally he comes face to
face with Lydia he and Olympia have
always had an interesting day
and I felt and calls absence he became
very fond of her and wished to right the
wrongs that had come from the young
boy's death out on the road Mary gets to
hold the baby once more and she even
throws herself into danger to draw the
Horde away it really shows how much he's
grown as a character and how she's
willing to do something for the greater
good the whisperers were always loyal to
alpha and they lacked independence
however here she shows that she's broken
free and from this can make her own
decisions
unfortunately for her a big gut punch or
rather gut stab comes from betta who
sneaks up behind her and kills her she
manages to Tara's mask off or rather his
true face and this could exemplify that
all of the humanity has gone from him we
can see that the face underneath is just
as black as the flesh that he wears to
cover it and it's a really nice moment
packed with a lot of subtext another
whisperer spots him and instantly
recognizes him which shows that the
series is following the comics and
having him be a celebrity in the comic
books he was a basketball player turned
actor and this looks like he could carry
over to the show however fear the
walking dead may have already showed who
he really is in season 5 episode 14 we
could see a record that could have been
one of betas releases and this shows why
he's instantly recognizable it also
explains why he's so protective over his
mask and he will likely be trying to
avoid Fame now that the world has ended
it's a nice little hint of things to
come that I definitely think will pay
off down the line watching Mary
reanimate is heartbreaking and she
spared the punishment of being trapped
in the whisperers as one of their dead
by an arrow to the head just just
probably probably should have shot betta
though but never mind miko saw Magne
using the horace camouflage and we
discovered that after they were
separated she fled underground since
escaping the cave she's been moving with
them and this has given her time to
realize the dire situation that they're
truly in the pair agreed to break up and
both seemed to take it really well like
it like it actually seems like a mutual
breakup which as we know on the whole
that these tend to be lies because yeah
your girlfriend dumped you and that's
why you start watching Walking Dead
breakdowns on YouTube it wasn't mutual
you didn't agree to it
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
anyway eugene and carol also get a
really awesome exchange and even she
tells him that he should go for it and
meet the voice at the other end of the
line everyone's living day to day and if
it's your last one on earth then you
should probably throw caution to the
wind there's different journeys with
different members but the ark that gets
the most attention is that of the kids
who are hiding out with ill ill
unfortunately got bit when trying to
rescue them and i can't lie i was
tearing up a bit as i saw about to do
the Joker's pencil trick from the dark
knight he deserves an emmy for the scene
as it's absolutely incredible acting and
yet I really really got to me Judith is
also getting over committing her first
murder and it's just packed with
emotional beats we cut to negan telling
alpha that he's found Lydia and as we
know alpha told the whisperers that
Lydia was dead but she doesn't seem to
care
alpha tells negan that she wants him to
go out into the world and spread the
word of the whisperers she wants him to
be a lion but negan rebuffs this saying
that it's supposed to be the young lion
that takes the lionesses place negan
discussed his life before the apocalypse
and which he lost his Lucille to cancer
and seeing this loss puts everything
into perspective this death sent negan
spiraling into becoming a vicious man
that we grew to hate and he showcases
how detached he became similar to the
comics he calls our alpha for actually
having emotions and hiding this from
everyone in order to lead them as he's
truly detached he knows when other
people aren't and that she's just
putting it on for everyone we all know
alpha won't really kill her own daughter
and negan has came to this conclusion
knowing that she still loves her even
after all they've been through as alpha
approaches when negan's locked her up we
realized that it's all one big trap and
that Lydia is actually at another
location
negan cuts alphas throat and one of the
biggest moments in the show so far and
even though I knew it was coming or was
still completely shocked by it
negan kisses her and it's revealed that
this entire time
negan has had his own mission he heads
back to the survivors with alphas
reanimated head and tosses it to Carol
who says took you long enough
mirroring alpha sending Dante in to
infiltrate the survivors Carol alphas
opposite did the same thing with him
it's been a chess game this entire time
and seeing this reveal was absolutely
incredible
if you think back to when negan was
first freed Lydia said that she was the
one who did it but Daryl suspected that
this was a lie we never quite had it
confirmed exactly which character let
that beast out of the cage but now we
know that it was Carol going forward
there are a lot of things that could
happen with negan potentially going back
undercover to take down bata who will
become the leader of the group in alphas
absence there's a lot of things up in
the air but overall this season has been
brilliant I think that they will connect
with the Commonwealth soon through
Eugene and this will add to their
numbers expanding in case you don't know
the Commonwealth are actually their own
little civilization with things like
shops barbers and probably the internet
so they can watch more terrible
breakdowns like this they're really what
society are aiming for and I can see
them coming together and possibly being
the location where Rick Grimes is
currently at there's a lot of things to
look forward to but I have really
appreciated the season and it's been
great at getting my good will for the
series back I will be covering more key
episodes as they drop so definitely keep
an eye out for them going ahead on the
channel now obviously I'd love to hear
your theories on the Walking Dead and
what you've thought of the season so far
if you enjoy this video then please drop
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of Westworld season 3
episode 1 which is gonna be linked at
the end every month on the 15th we give
away free blu-rays and all you have to
do to being with a chance of winning the
Star Wars Skywalker saga box set is
leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come check us
on our discord server linked in the
description or at definition whitey on
Twitter those are the best ways to keep
up to date with the channel so hopefully
we see over there very soon this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]